Let us now examine
what conditional
probabilities are good for.
We have already discussed that
they are used to revise a
model when we get new
information, but there is
another way in which
they arise.
We can use conditional
probabilities to build a
multi-stage model of a
probabilistic experiment.
We will illustrate this through
an example involving
the detection of an object
up in the sky by a radar.
We will keep our example
very simple.
On the other hand, it turns
out to have all the basic
elements of a real-world
model.
So, we are looking up in the
sky, and either there's an
airplane flying up
there or not.
Let us call Event A the event
that an airplane is indeed
flying up there, and we have
two possibilities.
Either Event A occurs, or the
complement of A occurs, in
which case nothing is
flying up there.
At this point, we can also
assign some probabilities to
these two possibilities.
Let us say that through prior
experience, perhaps, or some
other knowledge, we know that
the probability that something
is indeed flying up there is
5% and with probability 95%
nothing is flying.
Now, we also have a radar that
looks up there, and there are
two things that can happen.
Either something registers
on the radar
screen or nothing registers.
Of course, if it's a good radar,
probably Event B will
tend to go together with Event
A. But it's also possible that
the radar will make
some mistakes.
And so we have various
possibilities.
If there's a plane up there,
it's possible that the radar
will detect it, in which case
Event B will also happen.
But it's also conceivable that
the radar will not detect it,
in which case we have
a so-called miss.
And so a plane is flying up
there, but the radar missed
it, did not detect it.
Another possibility is that
nothing is flying up there,
but the radar does detect
something, and this is a
situation that's called
a false alarm.
Finally, there's the possibility
that nothing is
flying up there, and the radar
did not see anything either.
Now, let us focus on this
particular situation.
Suppose that Event
A has occurred.
So we are living inside this
particular universe.
In this universe, there are two
possibilities, and we can
assign probabilities to these
two possibilities.
So let's say that if something
is flying up there, our radar
will find it with probability
99%, but will also miss it
with probability 1%.
What's the meaning of
this number, 99%?
Well, this is a probability that
applies to a situation
where an airplane is up there.
So it is really a conditional
probability.
It's the conditional probability
that we will
detect something, the radar will
detect the plane, given
that the plane is already
flying up there.
And similarly, this 1% can be
thought of as the conditional
probability that the complement
of B occurs, so the
radar doesn't see anything,
given that there is a plane up
in the sky.
We can assign similar
probabilities
under the other scenario.
If there is no plane, there is
a probability that there will
be a false alarm, and there is
a probability that the radar
will not see anything.
Those four numbers here
are, in essence, the
specs of our radar.
They describe how the radar
behaves in a world in which an
airplane has been placed in
the sky, and some other
numbers that describe how the
radar behaves in a world where
nothing is flying
up in the sky.
So we have described various
probabilistic properties of
our model, but is it
a complete model?
Can we calculate anything that
we might wish to calculate?
Let us look at this question.
Can we calculate the
probability that
both A and B occur?
It's this particular
scenario here.
How can we calculate it?
Well, let us remember the
definition of conditional
probabilities.
The conditional probability of
an event given another event
is the probability of their
intersection divided by the
probability of the conditioning
event.
But this doesn't quite help us
because if we try to calculate
the numerator, we do not have
the value of the probability
of A given B. We have the value
of the probability of B
given A. What can we do?
Well, we notice that we can
use this definition of
conditional probabilities,
but use it in the reverse
direction, interchanging the
roles of A and B. If we
interchange the roles of A and
B, our definition leads to the
following expression.
The conditional probability of
B given A is the probability
that both events occur divided
by the probability, again, of
the conditioning event.
Therefore, the probability that
A and B occur is equal to
the probability that A occurs
times the conditional
probability that B occurs
given that A occurred.
And in our example, this is
0.05 times the conditional
probability that B occurs,
which is 0.99.
So we can calculate the
probability of this particular
event by multiplying
probabilities and conditional
probabilities along the path
in this tree diagram that
leads us here.
And we can do the same for any
other leaf in this diagram.
So for example, the probability
that this happens
is going to be the probability
of this event times the
conditional probability of
B complement given that A
complement has occurred.
How about a different
question?
What is the probability, the
total probability, that the
radar sees something?
Let us try to identify
this event.
The radar can see something
under two scenarios.
There's the scenario where there
is a plane up in the sky
and the radar sees it.
And there's another scenario
where nothing is up in the
sky, but the radar thinks
that it sees something.
So these two possibilities
together make up the event B.
And so to calculate the
probability of B, we need to
add the probabilities
of these two events.
For the first event, we
already calculated it.
It's 0.05 times 0.90.
For the second possibility,
we need to do a similar
calculation.
The probability that this occurs
is equal to 0.95 times
the conditional probability of B
occurring under the scenario
where A complement has occurred,
and this is 0.1.
If we add those two numbers
together, the answer turns out
to be 0.1445.
Finally, a last question, which
is perhaps the most
interesting one.
Suppose that the radar
registered something.
What is the probability
that there is an
airplane out there?
How do we do this calculation?
Well, we can start from the
definition of the conditional
probability of A given B, and
note that we already have in
our hands both the numerator
and the denominator.
So the numerator is this number,
0.05 times 0.99, and
the denominator is 0.1445, and
we can use our calculators to
see that the answer is
approximately 0.34.
So there is a 34% probability
that an airplane is there
given that the radar
has seen or thinks
that it sees something.
So the numerical value of this
answer is somewhat interesting
because it's pretty small.
Even though we have a very good
radar that tells us the
right thing 99% of the time
under one scenario and 90%
under the other scenario.
Despite that, given that the
radar has seen something, this
is not really convincing or
compelling evidence that there
is an airplane up there.
The probability that there's an
airplane up there is only
34% in a situation where
the radar thinks
that it has seen something.
So in the next few segments, we
are going to revisit these
three calculations and see
how they can generalize.
In fact, a large part of what is
to happen in the remainder
of this class will
be elaboration
on these three ideas.
They are three types of
calculations that will show up
over and over, of course, in
more complicated forms, but
the basic ideas are essentially
captured in this
simple example.